you can't help change what you fear ah
you know what i'm saying so so some of
the people that we deal with you know
they they
they are they can be scary they can be
rough but we understand that if we want
to make an impact we can't fear what
we're trying to help
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living in this tent on top of this
rooftop for 100 days from november 20th
to february 28th bringing to you the
awareness that you need about the gun
violence on the south side of chicago
and trying to raise as much money as we
possibly can to build a much-needed
center on this block called o-block it's
called o-block because it's named after
a young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs picked up the o in
his name and started calling it o-block
we decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox for giving me
this opportunity every single day every
single evening to bring to you
my rooftop revelations where i discuss
my own thoughts my own opinions and
viewpoints as it relates to what's going
on
in our country and in our city
i'm really thankful today i have a very
special friend my brother my assistant
pastor tj who's here with me today and
we're going to jump right in tj thanks
for being with us i know it's cold at
night right
it's real cold the wind is blowing so i
i hope they don't hear all this wind but
you know if you do please forgive us we
want to jump in on the subject that's
real important you know there's a lot of
kids who've been getting shot
and you know one of the things that i've
been passionate about and i've been
telling you about we've been planning
about
is that while i've been on this roof god
has really been
speaking to my heart about kids children
and teenagers and
you know just recently we had five
uh kids who in less than 24 hours who
were shot and killed
and i believe tj and i want to know what
you think
that what we need to have happen is that
we need our churches
to step up big time
in chicago on the south side and west
side we have churches everywhere
everywhere and we have a lot of great
pastors who pastor these churches
but i'll be the first to say even me
even you even our church we've not done
enough
for young people
do you think that maybe
we could solve
a lot of these issues with the violence
if our churches would get more engaged
definitely definitely and and pastor
it's one thing to get
engaged it's another thing to get
engaged together
oh wow you can you can have a collection
of churches
but having a connection of churches is
totally different and so i think what
happens is we get caught up in being in
our own islands in our own silos
and i think it's one of two parts one is
you know a little bit of ego and two i
think that sometimes we wonder if god is
really big enough to handle our work in
somebody else's wow and so um i believe
that he is and i believe what the
scripture says about if you're faithful
of another man's work he'll make sure he
gives you your own and so i think that
we have to get to a place where we can
really say you know what let's get
plugged into somebody that's already
doing the work let's not recreate the
wheel and then let's go ahead and help
save our city and our young people yeah
you know you know i've been thinking
really hard and long about
uh what we need with uh
to do for these young people
but how critical is it if churches
don't step up and get more involved just
how critical is it i think i think it's
extremely critical because i think
that's where the whole that's where the
whole is that's what the void is um our
job is to step in and fill the gap and
give direction so if there's no church
there's no direction and people become a
law unto themselves and that's what we
don't want to happen and so um i believe
that places like new beginnings and
other churches in the uh in our city if
we come together i think that we have
the tools and the blueprint to help give
guidance and to help give instruction
and also to help love on these teenagers
and these young people in areas and in
ways that they're not seeing at home and
you know our job is to love and to show
love and i think that once we operate in
our proper place we can add that to the
table to help bring them out of what
they're in yeah do you think that
churches are going to have to make some
adjustments and some changes definitely
i think i think we really got to start
thinking out of the box i think we got
to start getting out of the box beyond
the four walls which is what i'm so
grateful that this church does um i
think that we're really going to have to
start looking at ourselves in the mirror
and saying what is my priority and and
am i truly and truly truly truly
concerned about what's going on in my
city and if i am what am i doing to make
sure that i'm playing my part to make
that change
yeah you know i think it's vitally
important that
uh the churches get more engaged
that we collaborate even more
that we totally have to get out of the
box that's one of the reasons why we
created project good because we wanted
an avenue to reach more young people and
we wanted the opportunity for our church
to be able to express that avenue and
work in that avenue you know to engage
and win more young people you know what
pastor the thing that i love about you
know the church and project hood and i'm
a firm believer in this you can't help
change what you fear ah you know what
i'm saying so so
some of the people that we deal with you
know they they
they are they can be scary they can be
rough but we understand that if we want
to make an impact we can't fear what
we're trying to help and what we're
trying to change and so we get our hands
dirty you've taught us to to get out
there not be fearful because once you
show love it will be reciprocated
because that may be the first time that
they've ever received it and seen it in
their own eyes absolutely you know in
close i just want to say you know i
really do believe that the local church
is the hope of the world and in our
culture
we've always had the church in the
forefront
uh when we were without colleges it was
the church that started hbcus when when
we needed the civil rights movement it
was the church that was in the forefront
the abolitionists uh abolishing slavery
it was the church that was in the
forefront and now here we are
uh
removed from those things
but it's just as critical just as dire
and i really do believe that just like
in the past
how the church was in the forefront of
bringing about transformation
i really do believe
we're going to need the church to step
up big time absolutely yeah so man thank
you thank you for sharing your ministry
with me and teaming in ministry with me
you are a flat out bonafide preacher
teacher and friend and i appreciate you
in all the things that you do thank you
and all the support work that you give
listen it's been a blessing we believe
that we got to get the churches involved
so pray for us to make that happen if
we're ever going to see transformation
happen in our community we have to get
these churches
as pastor tj said to get out the box
listen it's been great it's been awesome
wonderful talk and discussion
thank you to fox for giving me this
opportunity again i really really
appreciate it and like i always say
i'll talk to you all tomorrow
until then
peace
you